you guys thought i was lying about the
orange but here
exhibit a
bone apple tea
everyone's giving me faces in this room
but don't judge until you've tried it
what's up gq it's justin h min and today
i'm going undercover on the internet
dun dun dun
it's actually me
i need a password this
let's do it
twitter variety tweets best known for
his work as ben hargreaves in the
umbrella academy justin h min will next
be seen in the titular rule in the film
after game playing a robot family member
at mia bear 713 responds with first a
ghost and now a robot i swear justin
never plays any characters that are
actually alive
yes mia you're correct for now i have uh
been fortunate enough to play some very
interesting characters and
serendipitously they both happen to be
dead now for the next phase of my career
i would love to play characters that are
breathing and alive that's the next step
i think
at liz simping tweets guess who sing
after yang tomorrow and to that at spin
stats with two z's responds with we got
about two more seconds before justin h
is at the top i bet this was a dream
role or wonder what his dream role is
not sure why i'm reading the tweets like
this apologies this was absolutely a
dream role kogo nada is a dream director
of mine i've been a fan of his visual
essays and so when i got the script in
my hands and had the opportunity to
audition i was
just
just so thankful even for the chance to
audition and then when i heard i got the
role i mean wow next there are two
photos of me eating an orange
my goodness does he really eat the peel
first good fiber i guess
absolutely with every fiber of my being
pun intended
i eat the skin with the orange it gives
you you know a bit more of that
zest and also who has the time to peel
fruits so i'll just eat it it's the
easiest way
no but i'm seriously try it out try it
out it's good
read it
i'm seeing a photo of
me
and
a shrine of some sorts it's actually
titled the justified shrine
interesting is there a specific reason
why he signed a can of bush's baked
beans i signed them because i was asked
to sign them someone came up to me and
asked me to sign this can of beans and
why not you know
why not sign beans why not sign fruit
why not sign anything anything is
signable and
apparently
it became part of the shrine so
hats off to you baked beans
ad frogs are [ __ ] why are you so mean
to frogs they're not [ __ ] they're
quite kind so there was a scene that
showed klaus realizing reacting to the
fact that ben is gone and they cut it
why
was there a scene like that i
there could have been
i did think that it was a bit odd that
there wasn't a larger scene that
addressed that because obviously ben and
klaus had the closest relationship but
who knows you might
see some of that answered in the next
season
in season three is there only going to
be the evil ben i assume you mean
sparrow ben and
i think it's a bit presumptuous that
you're saying he's evil i mean you've
known him for what all of five seconds
maybe he's a good guy maybe he was just
having a rough day please don't judge
until you see him and yes you are gonna
be seeing more of that guy in season
three it was such
a pleasure and joy to film this new
version of ben especially after playing
a different version of ben for the last
two seasons and i hope you guys uh love
him as much as you love the other ben i
have a feeling you won't
but
try
wikipedia he then attended cornell
university where he served on the
student assembly as the minority liaison
he graduated from the school's college
of arts and sciences in 2011 with
degrees in government and english
how do they find this out this is true
it's also very embarrassing i apologize
to cornellians across the world i will
try to do better and yes i did serve on
the student assembly as the minority
liaison one of my biggest initiatives
was to help bring more asian american
classes and courses to the campus
and yes i studied government in english
do i use those today
no
he is fluent in korean and is the second
cousin of ashley park
yes
justin
i think interview is in tupu in korean
and absolutely i am a second cousin of
ashley park fun fact we actually only
found that out a couple of years ago her
family moved away and so we sort of lost
touch and it was only in the last couple
of years that we've been able to
reconnect and i'm so happy for her
success it's
so crazy that we're both in this
industry i'm glad i get to do with
family quora
how would you rank the umbrella academy
netflix series kids on their
intelligence on a scale of one through
seven
luther
one diego
one alison
three
klaus
one
five
five
six
seven
seven
six
who is the most powerful character in
netflix's the umbrella academy if we're
talking figuratively that the award
definitely goes to
reginald daddy hargreaves i mean the
amount of trauma that that man has
inflicted upon his children
it's the reason why we're all
dysfunctional in the first place youtube
ever thought what would happen if ben
became a person again
ben and klaus spent every second
together so class would become lonely
and then
he's seen everything through classes
perspective so life ain't gonna be easy
for him i don't think he sees everything
just through klaus's perspective i mean
he observes the world as is so
in many ways he's grown up alongside
klaus so i think if he were to become a
person he would be perfectly fine on his
own as would klaus and at the end of the
day they're still family so they would
still see each other they'd probably
just be roommates doesn't he give the
vibe of a brand new human who just
landed on earth and is learning as he
goes
honeybee responds that's because he's a
pisces you know what i feel seen through
that comment i actually do i feel like
i'm just getting the hang of things
john hargreaves says why is he my
favorite human
i wonder if he has any hidden talents
none none john
simply the bee says i want to know what
it's like working with colin farrell
especially for justin dream come true
the first time i met colin farrell was
at a fitting i accidentally walked into
his dressing room where he was getting
changed
he looked me dead in the eyes
and said
you're beautiful
my knees got shaky
what a way to meet someone especially to
colin farrell i was absolutely honored
he was one of the most generous
kind-hearted actors to work with and it
was a master class to watch him on set
every day
all right how about
instagram any good book recommendations
for a starter from zath20
and croc period idyll mr justin please
what are your favorite books the public
needs to know i love love reading i love
reading more than books
books
i love reading more than people i love
books more than people is what i meant
to say you know interestingly enough i
usually really love fiction
but i've been on this sort of
non-fiction
self-help
kick for the last couple of months i'm
not sure why i just finished atomic
habits by james clear
i think it's a really great book and it
really helps
change habits in your life
in a way that's sustainable
in a way that
will really work because i know
for me it's hard to break bad habits
sometimes and hard to pick up good ones
glittery raindrops says are you implying
this is going to be your last season
no absolutely not absolutely not do you
think that they would try to kill me for
a third time maybe who knows
in
rocio underscore a
says what do you do to be pretty every
day justin
that's
that's very kind of you
um
i don't know stay hydrated
put sunscreen on
be thankful for things
and
be a nice person i think that's what
will ultimately make you a pretty person
okay gq that is it i am signing off the
internet
and probably signing back in in about
three minutes